this is the message saying this app has
been such a game changer to me i've
never been so consistent with my quran
reading before i knew about quran lead
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
this is how people's lives are changing
and you can get quran li absolutely free
no credit cards for seven day free trial
what are you waiting for download it in
our own sisters and build a habit with
the quran the app right now
assalamu alaikum today better character
brothers and sisters in different so
hope you guys are winning shout outs so
a lot of people been messaging me
regarding this whole travis
whether his name scott con whoever he is
i don't really know and they've been
asking me to make comments about it i
don't really like making comments if
there is nothing to make comments on um
and there was a few people who lost
their lives because of the whole carnage
that happened the chaos that happened in
the
event even i heard sadly some a muslim
and his wife died you know so it is sad
is sad that you know these people dying
there you don't know if you should be
upset or cried that the fact that they
died or the fact of where they died you
know um so anyways um one of the things
that came to my mind about my sisters
was a narration from aisha and her of
the prophet peace be upon him that he
said on the day of judgment that when
everyone's resurrected they're gonna be
naked right
and um aisha and her obviously thinking
about he said look like won't people
look at each other like there's gonna be
naked men and naked women and the
process of said the math is gonna be so
severe that people are not concerned
about you know oh there's a buff thing
there oh that guy's handsome or look
that
there's nothing now if we take that to
the concert and see that the tragedy
that that happened
when they were there partying clubbing
drugs
you know fun whatever you want to call
it define funnest yeah okay i don't
think that's fun but anyways so they're
having fun uh listening to music um
maybe talking to the opposite gender
kissing whatever it may be okay
especially for men you know looking at
opposite agenda dressed up half naked
all these kind of stuff but what's very
interesting is that
a lot of people described it as like you
know like a concert from hell or
something like that now if you think
about it guys in that very moment when
this chaos was happening everybody
forgot about the music everybody forgot
about the the singers the famous people
they forgot about them they didn't want
nothing to do with them everyone forgot
about the opposite gender everybody
forgot about the music everyone forgot
about the alcohol and the drink and the
fun and the laughter everything stopped
people were shouting stop the show stop
the show why because their life was in
danger the moment their life was in
danger they forgot about the entire
world
now this is something that we need to
reflect on if in the dunya when the life
is at risk in that moment and people are
panicking and shocked and like i might
die or people are dying they're seeing
people dying and people going to the
cameraman and saying stop the show
just for a glimpse imagine and this is
to save yourself from death
what about on your makiyam on the day of
judgment
when people would come and they see the
hellfire and they know there is no more
death
it's not even a matter of dying being
scared of the unknown now you know
what's in front of you there's no more
death
there's no more death in islam we
believe that when
death is brought as like a a ram uh or
some kind of an animal and slaughtered
there is no more death people in
paradise will live forever and the
people of hell will live forever
i want you guys to imagine that moment
brothers and sisters if this can happen
in the dunya and people panic like this
on your qiyamah imagine the regret
imagine
this is your opportunity brothers and
sisters for you to reflect and say wow
allah has given you a glimpse with these
things tragic events that happen and
where people run for their life they
don't care about anybody
not mom not they don't care when your
qiyamah the mom will [ __ ] the child into
the fire instead of herself and the
child would do the same you might be
thinking how
that day you've got the hellfire in
front of you nobody is going to
sacrifice their self for no one
so in a nutshell that was my reminder
problem sister that's the only thing i
can think about this whole conspiracy of
satanic look
i'm gonna get into that you get it i've
been the whole industry satanic anyways
so i'm gonna get into this that et
cetera but that's what i wanted to share
with you guys brother sisters and hope
you guys have benefited from this share
this with your friends and family as a
reminder until next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh do
not forget to subscribe to our new
channel dining to jannah where we review
restaurants all around the world
actually
and give little subtle reminders
inshaallah till next time salaam alaikum
warahmatullahi